Sí muy buenas tardes pues con la llegada
de la presidente del gobierno de España
Pedro Sánchez aquí arrabat ha arrancado
la esperada reunión de alto nivel con la
que se quiere estabilizar las relaciones
entre España y Marruecos Y es que estos
países atravesaron una grave crisis
diplomática en los últimos años crisis
que se acabó resolviendo después de que
el gobierno español anunciara
públicamente su apoyo al plan de
autonomía que propone Marruecos para
resolver el conflicto del Sahara
occidental y ya pues lo cierto es que
estamos ante una Cumbre que no se
celebraba desde el año 2015 y que llega
en realidad en un momento delicado
porque pues porque hace unas semanas el
parlamento europeo aprobó una resolución
crítica condenando la falta de libertad
de prensa aquí en Marruecos y también
los supuestos casos de corrupción en la
Europa cámara vinculadosa a este país O
solamente votaron en contra de dicha
resolución pues la extrema derecha
Europea y precisamente el partido
socialista que gobierna en España y el
presidente del gobierno español Pedro
Sánchez llegó aquí a rabat acompañado de
12 ministros de su partido también se
reunió con el presidente del gobierno de
Marruecos
y después se trasladaron justo aquí a
este recinto donde se Está celebrando un
aforo económico hispano marroquí también
Sánchez mantuvo una conversación
telefónica con el sexto de Marruecos y
El Monarca invitó a la presidente
española a realizar otra visita oficial
a Marruecos Próximamente y ya pues Por
otra parte la sesión plenaria de esta
reunión de alto nivel llegará mañana
jueves se prevé que se firmen o muchos
acuerdos bilaterales Y que sobre la mesa
esté la cooperación económica la
seguridad las aduanas comerciales de los
enclaves españoles de ceuta y melilla y
el control migratorio